initiative rarissime emmanuel macron a
décidé de s'adresser aux députés et aux
sénateurs en faisant lire un texte au
sein des deux chambres du parlement à
cette communication sera lui dans
quelques minutes à 14h30 au sénat par
gérard lâcher et à l'assemblée nationale
par richard ferrand les présidents de
chaque chambre on va retrouver tout de
suite wassim cordes et en direct de
l'assemblée nationale bonjour ou asim
c'est une procédure exceptionnelle à
laquelle fait appel emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui la procédure du droit de
message qu'est ce que c'est exactement
bonjour natacha effectivement une
procédure exceptionnelle rarement
utilisé depuis le début de son
instauration dans la constitution c'est
une procédure qui est prévu par
l'article 18 de la constitution comme
vous l'avez dit qu'il s'appelle donc le
droit de messages la dernière fois que
ça avait lieu c'était en 2002 utilisé
par jacques chirac qui avait utilisé
cette procédure pour s'adresser aux donc
à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat lors
de la première session suite à
l'élection présidentielle qu'il avait
qui avait vu sa réélection donc en 2002
il avait même emmanuel macron l'avait
demandé donc dans son allocation hier
après midi avait dit qu'il enverrait un
message et qu'il serait lui de sa part
donc au parlement aux deux chambres donc
à l'assemblée et au sénat et donc il
sera lu simultanément par les présidents
des deux chambres richard ferrand pour
l'assemblée nationale et gérard larcher
par le sénat un point important donc qui
est prévu par cette constitution il n'y
aura ni débat ni vote suite à la lecture
de ce message merci beaucoup à sim
cordée en